assistant
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan uncensored tonight as
beer drinkers literally blast Bud Light
for promoting gender ideology is the
public second tired of Brands pushing
politics we'll debate that
swimmer Riley Gaines was physically
assaulted for standing up a woman's
rights in female sport then I got
applauded last week for standing up for
her she'll join me live
plus artificial intelligence makes a
Drake song with photography award and
learns fluent Bangladeshi without even
being asked to is Elon Musk right is AI
gonna kill us all
foreign
[Music]
Morgan uncensored advertising is
supposed to shove products down our
throats we all know that at their best
adverts make us smile laugh even cry
they make us associate brands with
feelings so that we'll buy them that's
the deal that's how it's been for
Generations but there's a new movement
in advertising they're no longer shoving
their products down our throats just
their identity politics and the only
feeling they're inspiring is Extreme
irritation well bud light's the most
popular beer in America for reasons
which are not entirely clear to anybody
at the moment they recently teamed up
with Dylan Mulvaney she was someone who
identified until very recently as a gay
man then non-binary and now apparently
is a woman and is an influencer who
makes kitchen videos about Womanhood and
being a girl from the vantage point of
to be honest a biological man
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too
well that went down as well as you could
be expected I guess the response from
budlett's customers was distinctly
unenthusiastic
and the new Bud Light thing I could be
this thing I could be that thing or I
could be anything I'm out
[Applause]
cancel Bud Light you see what it is we
ain't drinking Bud Light
[Music]
let me uh say something to all you and B
as clear and concise as possible
a little over the top there from Kid
Rock now I personally think unleashing
Hellfire on cases of Bud Light was a
semi-automatic rifle is a slight
overreaction you could just choose to
buy a different beer there's every
British person will tell you it's not
really beer anyway it's kind of fizzy
urine but the serious point is that a
major brand is once again Force feeding
an ideology onto its customers that they
don't want to have many women were
rightly outraged when Nike used the very
same trans influencer to advertise
sports bras even though Dylan Mulvaney
has no breasts and these are not
isolated incidents of corporate Insanity
we had ads which promote taking the knee
ants which seemed to promote
mastectomies ads which promote black
lives matter and with pregnant men as
which wrap every single imaginable
product merchandise or service in the
rainbow pride flag and whether you
support those case causes or not many of
them I do the common theme is a business
promoting a world view that's kind of
irrelevant and unfamiliar to most of the
people currently buying their product
the most famous example of this was
Gillette the men's shaving company which
used to advertise like this
[Applause]
we give you all we have to give Contour
plus with lubricating strip you're the
best a man can get oh I made you proud
to be a man and that was the problem
unfortunately can't be proud to be a man
anymore can't be proud to be masculine
no no nothing laudable about a man who
works hard makes money as a bit of a
wife raises great kids and wins no no no
no no no no no no
Gillette thought there was a massive
problem with this so they launched in
the light of me too a man shaming attack
ad instead take a look at this
bullying the metoo movement against
masculinity is this the best a man can
get
is it
[Music]
we can't hide from it yeah
it's been going on far too long
I remember that ad coming out and I've
been a long time Gillette customer these
cheeks most nights get the old Gillette
treatment and it makes me feel like a
man masculine proud to be a man and
suddenly I had to feel ashamed I had to
feel like it was a monster and as I
could prove otherwise
why would Gillette do that why would it
make their millions of male customers be
ashamed to be a man well the reaction as
I predicted in the column the next day
uh was a disaster I think it cost some
nine billion dollars over the next six
months before eventually they just did a
reverse ferret and went straight back to
the old style advertising because Men
actually wanted to feel good about being
a man and that is still allowed just as
Budweiser clearly panicked by the
backlash to their use of Dylan Mulvaney
have suddenly released a patriotic eye
with wild horses Flags landmarks and a
lot of Burly men
well they played with the virtue
signaling fire and their fingers were
duly burned the message to the
advertisers is clear just shut up and
sell us your tat well joining me now is
political journalist Ava Santina and
host and author Leia Halpern we're
welcome welcome to both of you
um let me start with you uh I I can
almost predict the way these things are
going to go from the moment I see these
ads the moment the advertising companies
who are staffed by a lot of woke people
decide to go woke they invariably end up
nearly going broke
that's exactly correct and I just want
to backtrack just a little minute
because you did refer to Dylan as a she
and let's just be clear and live in
reality for a second Dylan is a man and
just like you mentioned with um Gillette
yes if you do go woke then yes you will
go broke they lost six billion dollars
in in their stock price and so it's very
clear there's just not an appetite for
it these major companies are so stupid
and it it really surprises me how they
think there is such a an appetite for it
there clearly isn't they don't know
their audience and it's just
embarrassing that the way that they had
to flip so quickly and create this
patriotic advert to me it shows they're
disingenuous and it's also really
important to remember that they don't
care they don't really care about these
social justice issues they're just doing
it to make money they're still
capitalists at the end of the day just
like all the other companies that do it
they really don't care yeah I mean Ava
this reminded me a little bit of the
England football team at the World Cup
in Qatar saying you know we're all going
to wear armbands to show that we're all
for Pride right and then the moment they
got told they were going to get booked
off came the armbands which made me
think they really care about gay rights
they cared about signaling their virtue
for gay rights right to the point
somebody might wave a yellow card at
them and might actually cause them a
little bit of a problem on the pitch so
it wasn't to me a principal stand and I
find with this I didn't really care
about the Bud Light I thought it was a
stupid thing to do because it clearly
backfired exactly how I could have
predicted the Nike one I think is more
problematic why because you as a woman
how comfortable do you feel about
someone who until last year was a gay
man of 25 suddenly without any surgery
starts doing Tick Tock videos saying I'm
now into Womanhood and I'm a girl on a
journey to go to being a girl and then
doesn't Nike have the sports bras for
women despite not having any breasts and
more importantly mocks the way women do
sport if you look at it as a misogynist
that's ridiculous it's not that is
ridiculous she's not mocking the way
that we should support and also can I
just say that was really rude from your
other guy I don't know what her name is
but Dylan she's a she I don't understand
why you'd need to open up your
commentary with that you're obviously
appealing to a certain way well she
would like to identify now as a she yeah
just
just but until last year she was a hit
importantly then she was
I know but it's complicated keeping up
with these people like Sam Smith who was
a gay man and he was non-binary then he
was gender fluid yeah I have no idea
what he is I thought he dresses up like
Satan all the time
um I don't know what Dylan Mulvaney
really is other than a lot of women
particularly in America have taken great
exception to the way Dylan Mulvaney
mocks women female Behavior because they
believe that Dylan Mulvaney is a
biological man this is the anti-trans
movement in America is very different to
what it is in Britain in Britain
feminists claim that it's because
they're worried about men invading their
spaces fine whatever in America it's a
conservative movement and it's because
they don't believe that these like that
trans women fit into society and it's
all out of this pent-up Christian
aggression that is quite disgusting yes
is where you're wrong because I actually
went on Bill Marshall we're going to
interview Riley Gaines later who's the
swimmer at the center of this big
brother Leah Thomas who's the
transgender swimmer crushing all the
women in swimming pools in America and
it's a very liberal crowd the Bill Marsh
show very liberal in Los Angeles I've
been on there before and got booed for
saying anything remotely contentious
that might go against woke when I
vigorously defended Riley Gaines against
a very aggressive female Democrat
politician who was trying to say that
she was doing it all for likes and you
know what was she doing and got to stand
up for Trans rights and who you know who
cares the audience cheered everything I
said in response and deafening silence
for her but that's a tiny little like
nobody told me that it's not just a
right-wing thing it's not it is a run
you're deluded if you think it's only
right wing people in the field as well I
I hate I hate how you've opened up this
debate and asked me if I find it
offensive as a woman or whatever I don't
care I don't care that Dylan doesn't
have breasts and wear sports in the same
way that we don't have double
mastectomies because of breast cancer
don't wear you know they wear a sports
bra as well it doesn't bother me what's
in people's pants or in people's you
know bras no I'm not preoccupied with
that do you care that Leo Thomas a six
foot four inch biological male who
competed unsuccessfully as a man at
swimming is now winning National
Championship swimming races against
biological female I think that's
extrapolating the argument you care
because
we're talking about we're talking about
the whole trans issue my argument to you
is do you care about that is she a woman
in my opinion she's a woman so you don't
care that's fine you think it's
perfectly Fair it was approved by the
Lord this is this is is that woman and
she's a biological male yeah but that's
like saying like who has a natural
physical Advantage which means she
crushes
so does Usain Bolt he's a man
superhuman man against his own
biological sex no but that's that's a
ridiculous parameter to have it's not
though you are built differently should
you be within certain restrictions or
measures there are many sprinters built
exactly like Usain Bolt that's that's
ridiculous
we see it again and again these
companies do this you say they don't
care but I'm not sure it's that I think
it's more that they care about appealing
to the woke crowd because a lot of them
are too scared not to
yeah that's absolutely correct and just
to your guess just because what I said
is Rue doesn't mean it's not reality
it's just rubbish this is just the
reality of it Dylan is a man he has XY
chromosomes I don't know why we're going
down this crazy weird
Powerpuff girl kind of reality why are
you so obsessed with what genitalia and
you know it's very concerning because if
a biological man is able to identify as
a woman because of how he feels without
having any surgery or anything like that
then where do we draw the line it
basically means that an unbiological man
can then identifies a little girl then
start having play dates with Secrets
let me ask her why not all right let me
ask you a question identifies that way
it's just it's okay
and it's a very very dangerous yeah let
me ask every question you mentioned
Usain Bolt what would you feel if Usain
Bolt something identified as a woman
that's a ridiculous question oh and you
know what it is come on that's funny
because you can't wake up tomorrow
morning and decide that you're a woman
and start competing literally what Leah
Thomas has done it takes two years in
the UK it takes two years it takes one
year to qualify as Athletics right okay
so Usain Bolt could could potentially
within a year with a bit of reduced
testosterone treatment he could Sprint
against women a huge reduction in
testosterone yeah okay it makes no
difference to body mass or size or power
but it would be it would it would alter
everything so you'd be fine would you be
fine with that if he suddenly didn't if
that's you respect his right to be a
woman yes it's not particular it is
ridiculous but not for the reasons you
think but because it could happen and
you think it's fair that's obscene that
is obscene would you be happy if you've
seen both identified as a woman and
began winning the race an argument out
of what are people's lives it's
happening with Leah Thomas but it's not
be what's happening after this argument
is people like Dylan are now going to
face extreme hate and extreme concern in
their Community people like Dylan
Mulvaney are making millions and
millions of dollars in my view making a
mockery of the trans issue for all
intents and purposes dylani is still a
biological male said no surgery at all
or testosterone is the perfect trans
person in your opinion it's not a
perfect trans person it's about what
that person is doing in advertising many
women feel is mocking what it is to be a
woman but did she want to be on bad
light or did Bud Light make the
ridiculous you know proposition to put
her on the can whose fault is it and
who's getting the blame and who's
getting attacked it's this poor woman in
the states no people I don't feel sorry
for doing my money she is laughing all
the way to the bank he she whatever you
want to call her
um the reality is the people that are
suffering I think are the unknown trans
people who I think are being exposed to
constant mockery through these kind of
things by the likes of Leah Thomas
crushing women in the pool by Dylan
Mulvaney making a mockery of the way
women wear sports bras and do gym work
and so on all of that is unhelpful to
regular trans people just trying to get
by and wanting to have a bit of fairness
and equality the moment you try and get
a new unfairness and inequality for any
group of people at the expense of
another group you lose it
I don't agree I know you do and you're
wrong uh Ava thank you very much Leia
thank you very much I'll sense of Nexus
aren't made by AI really art and is
artificial intelligence about to take
over the world or even as Elon Musk is
warned kill us
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
foreign
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember a if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh
never lies is that true take a look at
this Photograph it's the winner of a
Sony World photography award but the
artist who created it ended up rejecting
his prize after admitting he made it
during using artificial intelligence
well the use of AI is seemingly
everywhere these days but the more it's
used the more debate it creates just
this afternoon a song that uses AI to
clone the voices of Drake and the
weekend to the biggest selling artist in
the world has been removed from
streaming services after singing
criticism from their music company over
copyright laws first let's just have a
listen to what they normally sound like
I guess we'll never know where Harvard
gets us but seeing my family have it all
took a place of that desire for diplomas
on the wall and really I think I like
who I'm becoming there's times where I
might do it just to do it like it's
nothing
well now here's the AI version of Drake
of the weekend
[Music]
absolutely fascinating well joining me
now is next year at a music industry
Legend and now the chief executive of
Tika or To Catch a Thief an anti-piracy
business and from Israel historian and
his battling author of sapiens Yuval
Noah Harari well welcome to both of you
and Nick Stuart Great Piece of my
telegraph today which you were quoted
about this song and about that
photograph
really I think demonstrating what a
threat AI is to the creative arts my
question for you is how serious do you
think that thread is and should it
really matter or is this in its own way
another form of Art
well the threat is huge we're on the
edge of a precipice and I'm not trying
to be too dramatic here um it's come
across so quickly as well that's the
point
this the two tracks that you played I
think people need to understand the
original it was done by by Drake in the
weekend the AI generator listens to all
Drake and all weekend and then puts
something together that comes out as the
second track you played so it's there's
no artist involved it is completely
generated I said here's my question for
you yeah I saw you tapping your fingers
to the AI version spontaneous yeah
you've got to stop yourself right it's a
good tune
why should we care why does it matter
why couldn't Drake and we can actually
think you know what this saves us a lot
of work okay
two things one is there's a British
copyright law which dates back to 1988
so it's a you could say it's a bit out
of date and it's been tinkered with
the other thing is passing off which is
not actually on the statute book passing
off has been handed down through
precedence through judges and passing
off is what this is which is why it's
been removed exactly but let me ask you
this what if Drake in the weekend like I
said what if they decided to adopt this
technology to save them having to come
up with new songs
could it be a force for good no artists
don't do that even if it was a big hit
it's a good song well
I know what you're suggesting yeah
artist and I'm sure if Drake was here he
would say and he got very cross about
another track that had been similarly
dealt with artists want to do their own
stuff that's what they're in the game
for we've had situations in the past
with groups who've been doing
rip-offs and samples and all the rest of
it real artists want to do their music I
don't want anybody but what about the
photograph which was a beautiful
photograph so good it won an award
before the guy who did it said well
actually hey I created this as a lover
of great photography why should we care
if that's been done by artificial
intelligence or by an actual human being
because they've infringed it's taken it
was done from the Getty Library wasn't
it so what they did they went into the
Getty library and they just picked it
again they scraped it all out and up it
came and they scraped it so well so it's
thefts basically it's theft yeah okay
let me bring in Hoover I want to start
if I may UVA by playing this is a clip
from Elon Musk talking to Tucker Carlson
on Fox news last night very interesting
what he said
I'm going to start something which
called Truth gbt or
a maximum truth seeking AI
that tries to understand the nature of
the universe and I think this this might
be the best path to Safety in the sense
that uh an AI that cares about
understanding the universe uh it is
unlikely to annihilate humans because we
are an interesting part of the universe
so evil this came after he said that
actually AI could lead to the end of
humanity as we know it if we allow
because it would be a superior
intelligent Force which if it managed to
break out from Human control could be
the end of us and that reminded me of a
conversation I had with Professor
Stephen Hawking in what was his last
television interview which he said this
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it
ever since the start of the Industrial
Revolution there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
instead the demand for goods and
services has risen in line with the
increased capabilities
whether this can continue indefinitely
it's an open question but there is a
greater Danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing first and it can improve
itself rapidly when we may lose control
so really interesting that Elon Musk
really is now saying what Professor
Hawking told me I mean you're an expert
in this field how worried should we be
about artificial intelligence actually
taking control
we should be very worried because what
we need to understand about AI
artificial intelligence it is the first
tool that can make decisions by itself
all previous inventions in human history
always empowered us they always gave us
more power because the decisions were
always made by humans if you invent a
knife the knife cannot decide whether to
use it to cut salad or to murder
somebody or to save their life in
surgery if you invent an atom bomb
similarly the atom bomb cannot decide
who to attack and when and where AI is
the first technology that can actually
make decisions by itself it can make
decisions about its own usage and
development
nukes cannot make better nukes but AI
can make better an eye and also AI can
make and does make decisions about us
increasingly when you apply to a bank to
get a loan you apply to a to get a job
it's an AI making crucial decisions
about your life and we haven't seen
anything yet AI is just making its first
tiny baby steps it's something like 10
years old you know to really think about
it think about it as like this is the
beginning of organic life
4 billion years ago this is the first
amoeba crawling out of the organic soup
can you imagine how Tyrannosaurus Rex
would look like or how Homo sapiens
would look like and what we'll be able
to okay when you look you successfully
you successfully yeah look you
successfully terrified me and probably
all my viewers so how do we save
ourselves from the T-Rex of AI
well first of all it can also of course
be used for good and so far we are still
in control but we don't know for how
many years
and therefore we need to first of all
understand the capabilities of AI and
slow down its deployment to make sure
that we use it wisely and safely you
know the same way that a drug company
cannot just release a new medicine to
the public without going through a very
rigorous safety checks it should be the
same with AI
here's the problem it seems to me which
is it's fine to be well-meaning I mean
Elon Musk I think a lot of what he does
he's a Force for good in many ways you
know he all the stuff he's been involved
with is to try and I think help rather
than damage the planet but this AI
intelligence is going to get in the
hands of some pretty bad people with
some pretty popular regimes and they're
not going to have any qualms about
trying to get the edge over the west or
America or wherever it may be that's
where I see the real danger is it you
know a bit like nuclear weapons getting
into Rogue States hands is that once the
wrong people have control of this then
all hell could break loose
in the hands of the wrong people AI
could be the end of democracy AI could
also be the basis for the worst
totalitarian regimes in human history
because you know dictators always
dreamed about following everybody and
monitoring everybody all the time but
they could never do it because you know
even the Soviet Union you have 200
million Soviet citizens Stalin didn't
have 200 million KGB officers to follow
everybody around all the time and then
to analyze all you need millions of
analysts to analyze all the data you
collect okay AI now it is becoming
possible you don't need human agents to
follow our us around
but let me ask you you talked about it
being a Force for good I just had a
conversation with Nick Stewart here top
record company guy in the UK about how
it can be used for songs and how it can
be used for photography and so on
in the right hands in good creative
hands could AI become a really brilliant
tool for creativity
yes absolutely and again from
discovering new medicines to writing new
songs and producing new movies and so
forth it could
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no uh with the people's
Channel don't worry every little helps
for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speech writers here but
we do and I promise you discuss the
issues that matter to you yes I'm back
talk TV not with Morgan just before him
Monday to Thursday at 7 pm join me just
do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
coming at 7 pm on Friday it's time for
plank of the week that's right it's when
we decide who has been the biggest plank
this week hasn't been a politician
hasn't been a member of the royal family
or possibly too hasn't been a football
team has it been an entire country we
will bring you the nominations I will
bring you the actual Plank and the prize
is right in front of me here don't
forget it's talk TV it's me Mike Graham
and a gorgeous panel of great guests
it's all here it's 7 P.M on Friday
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
join me Ian Collins every day on talk TV
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers Alan in Grimsby
Tracy in Burton on Trent Dave thank you
very much picking apart the big stuff
this simply does not wash look who's
back under the spotlight
foreign
page to the last word bringing you
tomorrow's news today and revealing the
biggest stories as they develop
[Music]
first edition is the only place to get
ahead of the game
[Music]
every weeknight at 10 pm
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it first edition
only on talk TV
coming at 7 pm on Friday it's time for
plank of the week that's right it's when
we decide who has been the biggest plank
this week hasn't been a politician
hasn't been a member of the royal family
or possibly too has it been a football
team has it been an entire country we
will bring you the nominations I will
bring you the actual Plank and the prize
is right in front of me here don't
forget it's talk TV it's me Mike Graham
and a gorgeous panel of great guests
it's all here it's 7 P.M on Friday
[Music]
thank you
well that was exciting uh our sound desk
uh which is two days old today just
crashed so that's why we went off there
a little uh suddenly in the middle of
that said debated by AI as my mother
texted me oh my God has AI taken over
which actually was a pretty good way to
get it so I'm rejoined I hopefully by
our two guests next year is with me and
by you vile in Israel Israel my
apologies for the sudden uh departure
from you there uh technology if it works
when you need it yeah I don't think it
is AI but you can never be too sure
um I'll come to you in a moment just
just to round off you were telling me a
story in the break there about Oasis
tell me what what that was about as I'm
sure your viewers know Oasis the
Gallagher brothers broke up okay there
have been talk of reconciliation but at
the moment that's not on the table if
you go on YouTube you will find
something called Isis which is a i s i s
talking about a lost album an AI
generator has made and what's it like
it's it's uncannily good right so if
you're an oasis fan why would you not
want that no well the answer is
um yes you would and so but I mean in
terms of bands that have ceased I mean
would people go down the route of trying
to yeah I've got a bit of it here I
think
each day and I'm just wasted it away
[Music]
I'm gonna use faster let's go go to
uvault uh finally you've all give us end
on some hope here for us all right I I
need to feel more hopeful than than I do
right now because I basically think the
world's gonna end quite soon when these
when Terminator comes real
um do you believe that the planet has
the right people in the right place to
actually stop that happening
I hope so what you we know about
technology that you know you can use the
same technology to build completely
different Societies in the 20th century
some people used uh trains and radio and
electricity to build totalitarian
regimes like the Soviet Union and other
people used exactly the same technology
to build liberal democracies it's the
same with AI and with the Technologies
of the 21st century we still have a
choice about how to employ them I think
that AI is nowhere near its full
potential yeah but also human beings are
nowhere near our full potential we don't
really understand the full potential of
our brains of our minds if we invest for
if for every dollar and every minute
that we invest in developing AI will
invest another dollar a minute in
developing our own mind and our own
Consciousness I think will be okay
fascinating uh Yvonne Noah Harare thank
you you so much honestly a gripping
interview apologies for the interruption
there was a bit of a bit of drama always
goes down quite well everyone's like oh
what's happened uh next year great to
see you thank you thank you very much
indeed uh well some of Riley Gaines made
Global headlines when she tied with
athlete Leah Thomas who's a transgender
swimmer
um this is the person of course who's
been dominating now women's swimming in
America despite having competed
unsuccessfully as a biological male well
unlike many people in the same position
afraid of vilification abuse and
cancellation Riley spoke out about it he
took a stand for women's athletes across
the world
and as a result of that stand she was
last week physically assaulted and
abused and howled at after being invited
to speak at San Francisco State
University well this weekend I spoke up
for Riley Gaines in a debate on Bill
Maher's HBO show real time while
debating a democratic congresswoman
Katie Porter
we talked about people you know becoming
using things to kind of get likes and
get clicks that's not what she's doing
I've got no truck right against
personally but all I've seen her do is
stand up for women's rights to fairness
and equality she actually competed
against Leah Thomas and it was obviously
unfair Leah Thomas won one of the races
in the NCAA championships by 50 seconds
against a bunch of biological females
who simply couldn't keep up that cannot
be right it cannot be fair
that I trust I think our sporting bodies
should be dealing with and by the way
Riley is speaking up for herself
and that is her prerogative and I
respect her free speech I think she's
picking up with pretty much every female
athlete in the world
now that debate was astonishing on
several levels firstly that it fell to
Mead and Bill Maher to defend women's
rights against a woman arguing against
them and secondly the audience packed
with liberal Californians a pretty woke
crowd normally and we're watching a
famous liberal comedian aside it
overwhelmingly with Bill and me
defending Riley Gaines and women's
rights to fairness so I'm joined Now by
Riley against O'Reilly great to see you
um I don't know whether you've got a
chance to actually watch what went down
on the bill Marshall but it was
fascinating to see the audience reaction
because they completely agree with me
when I defended you and did not agree
with the woman in the room
absolutely
um when I watched this back I you just
can't help but laugh
just like you mentioned it's ironic it's
always women fighting against women's
sex protected spaces and rights it blows
my mind but I so appreciate both you and
Bill standing up for myself because you
hit the nail on the head I'm speaking
for every female athlete not just myself
if I'm done competing this isn't about
me
um but I know it's at stake if someone
doesn't use their voice I have a younger
sister I just got married I can only
hope one day that I have a daughter and
I can't imagine being in this position
and not fighting for them but also I'm
fighting for the present female athletes
Leah Thomas's teammates even who have
their voices suppressed they see what
happens to me when I go to San Francisco
State and they don't want to put
themselves in a position where speaking
out would would Garner that for them
right so it's a lot bigger than just
myself and to see representative Katie
Porter even say that it just it clearly
shows she knows nothing about what I've
been doing this past year nothing has
been for personal advancement nothing
has been for monetary value for me
um my I was supposed to be in Dental
School this year so by no means did I
even feel equipped to do what I'm doing
this is not about me and and hearing her
say that showed her true ignorance yeah
I completely I completely agree and in
fact Leah Thomas today tweeted the
following it breaks my heart to see
trans kids across the country lose out
on these opportunities during the time
of anti-trans backlash to trans
Community needs explicit protections
from discrimination in order to live our
lives free and equally all trans kids
deserve the opportunity to compete and
play on the sports they love without
compromising who they are now my problem
with that and I think you picked up on
this as well in your response to Leah
Thomas is well what about fairness and
equality for the women for biological
females because clearly what Leah Thomas
a six foot four inch biological male who
did not compete successfully against men
but is now demolishing women in National
Championships clearly that is unfair now
I want trans athletes to have fairness
and equality I want them to be able to
play sport but not at the expense of
women's rights
exactly the first sentence you you said
I believe it was it Leah Thomas quoted
saying you know it breaks my heart to
see trans kids lose out on opportunities
you're exactly right replace that with
the word woman does it still break
Thomas's heart to see women lose out on
opportunities because that's exactly
what's happening from my experience
competing against Leah Thomas at the
national championships I watch firsthand
women lose out on opportunities I watch
women not become all-americans missing
that ninth or the 8th and 16th Place by
one place because they were displaced by
a male this of course goes against
everything that Title IX was created to
protect and now we have the by
demonstration the people in the White
House who are actively working to
rewrite title ix9 for those who don't
know originated in the 70s were designed
to bring equality and fairness
irrespective of gender to schools and
education and in particular to school
Sport and clearly that is now not
happening and the Biden Administration
are effectively endorsing this
unfairness
absolutely that's exactly what they're
doing um Title IX it's a several civil
Federal rights law that insures women
essentially have the same opportunities
as men whether that be athletically
academically the same amount of
scholarships
we saw women fight for this in the 70s
we saw someone as as amazing as Billie
Jean King
um Megan rapino these are feminists who
fought for women's rights but now both
of these women along with the Biden
Administration they're actively working
to undermine everything they once fought
for well Megan rapino was out there
tweeting away that you know this is all
uh all fantastic and of course trans
athletes should be doing this and I made
the point uh well how would she have
felt if she'd lost her place of a
national women's soccer team which was
obviously they were world champions to a
trans athlete who was five inches taller
stronger faster and much better at
football but who had been unsuccessful
playing an immense team how would she
have felt then
well if you've ever seen Megan rapino
play she's a very tough aggressive
player so I can tell you exactly what I
think she would have done
um I think she genuinely would have
shift someone who tried to take her spot
a male who tried to take her spot and I
think it's worth mentioning that she's
done playing she has nothing to lose she
doesn't have a daughter to defend so for
her what to lose by by almost virtue
signaling by coming off as kind and
inclusive and welcoming and accepting
and tolerant and loving and all the
things but in reality it's not kind to
ask a girl to share a locker room with a
man who's fully equipped with an
exposing male parts and it's not
inclusive to ask a woman to smile and
step aside on the podium so a man can
take her Trophy and take her spot in her
honors yeah I just find this whole
debate completely baffling I don't
understand why every woman in the world
wouldn't join together and say this is
outrageous and it's the treachery from
women like the Democrat congresswoman
lady Porter like Megan rapino like these
others who who should be doing a lot
better than they are but you know what a
lot of women are scared they're scared
to do what you've done you know you went
to San Francisco State University and
you know you you're a fear of your life
with that mob and it was terrifying
absolutely it sure was I was essentially
I mean I know you saw the video but I
was physically assaulted and I was held
from ransom for three hours I mean these
people who barricaded me in this room
they were demanding money if I wanted to
make it home safely which then the dean
of students was actually negotiating
with them it's like well you know why
are we negotiating my safe passage home
this is crazy but you're exactly right
and these girls they're terrified
they're scared parents are even scared
they don't want to lose their job
coaches athletic directors no one wants
to be in a position where you you ruffle
feathers or step on toes but that's what
it's going to take it's going to take
sacrifices it's going to take girls not
willing to get up on that starting block
not jump when the gun blows we need
people who are willing to take that next
step and I know it's unfortunate that
it's come to this circumstances to have
to make change but that's what it's
going to take Riley you're a gutsy woman
I've got to tell you I've got great
admiration for you and what you go
through to make this point because it's
so important it's basically the
Integrity of women's sport is at risk
real risk of being irrevocably destroyed
and I think that people like you should
just be applauded by women around the
world for making the standard doing a
great personal risk to yourself so well
done to you keep it going and you'll
always have me in your corner of course
thank you so much Pierce all the best
thanks Roddy
extraordinary to be having this debate
isn't it isn't it
not get my head around it obviously it's
unfair well I'm sense of next uh my pack
could be waiting patiently hopefully AI
won't strike them down but actually
maybe AI could replace them might be
cheaper
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no out with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7 pm join me just do it well
that one two
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
we're coming up on The Talk The Women's
Institute is facing a Revolt as
campaigners say allowing transgender
women to join harms members Health
bosses ban doctors from calling patients
alcoholics and King Charles extends an
olive branch to Harry and Megan with a
prime spot in his coronation souvenir
program discussing all of that at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh nonsense I'm
joined now I've talked to the
contributor Paul around Adrian and talk
to the presenter Richard Tyson welcome
to both of you thank you an interesting
uh evening in many ways
um this whole issue of transgenderism it
seems to be just dominating the the
global debate right now in all different
ways what did you make of that interview
with with Riley Gaines there as you say
I mean she is remarkably brave but the
the grief that people are now getting
anybody who wants to talk about this
stuff how many Sexes there are how many
genders there are what trans women can
and can't do is it's actually terrifying
just this week I was taken down by Tick
Tock for suggesting there are two Sexes
two genders they said that was hate
speech and exciting violence and that's
the problem is there's we've lost any
respect for the alternative opinion this
comes to my general belief that
democratic debate is getting killed yeah
um what's the solution to this the
solution to this is and I
appreciate that this probably sounds
really prissy but the solution to this
is programs like this
teaching people that it is possible to
sit at a table with people that you
probably wouldn't do normally but to
engage in intelligence right I agree but
don't we have to start with some basic
respect for scientific facts this whole
drows debate it seems to me comes down
to whether you believe or not that
biological sex is irrefutable that you
are either born male or female and I
think if you don't sign up to that then
you're basically a denier of scientific
facts yes if we lived our lives on the
basis of scientific fact we wouldn't be
the human beings that we are it is a
very emotive topic and that is you can't
feel comfortable seeing six foot four
inch biological males dominating women
in sports sure I do think that sport is
a category that needs to be considered
but when we're talking about other
aspects of our daily life it worries me
that there is this level of
discrimination what about this issue of
the wi right who William Hager said
they've got to accept transgender
members this is what he said
on times radio there are transgender
people they have changed their gender
um this is part of our society now and
um I think a large National
organizations like the wi have to get
over that and get used to that
Richard he's completely wrong it's utter
nonsense
seriously do you know how hard it is to
be a woman no you don't which is what
you would choose to be a woman I just
want to let you into his little secret
here guys it's not easy being but that's
why those are being a man
that's why you should you think it's
easy being a man
I think if you are going to choose to be
a woman in the women's history that's
why women there used to be a woman
you're going to go through what could be
very very painful operations you are
going to change your life so that
Society you've just agreed with me women
feel so offended
I I want people who want to support
women to be to be part of the female
fight and if that includes a transgender
person why not the Clue's in the name
women's Institute you can have a trans
woman's Institute if you want why do we
need a trans woman Institute what about
a trans male Institute
about this is better than a lot I do
feel what is wrong with actually being a
trans woman and calling yourself that
and accepting you're not a biological
female you're a trans woman exactly and
celebrating that exact but not
diminishing women's rights or women's
institutions frankly if they want to
have that fine let them I don't think we
should be forcing these things on people
I think that's the way you alienate
people talk about AI I found that
interview with the Yuval Harare pretty
terrifying utterly terrifying I mean I
was learning especially following Elon
Musk and Stephen Colbert I mean the idea
and from what uh Professor Stephen
Hawking said people are now saying that
actually if this gets out of control it
could end the human race I mean we're
out of control isn't it and and that guy
said this is like an amoeba as we're
heading towards T-Rex his description
was what would it look like was was was
truly terrifying and we've got to get on
top of this urgently yeah and uh and
essentially sort of understanding so we
are looking into having a beers pack
which is basically robust
completely agree with you they'll look
and sound exactly like Paula and that's
how we know it'll be Ai and that's who
we know the end of the world tonight
they couldn't do Euro peers that's
that's beyond the limits I think I'm
beyond the road I'd like to think I am
because if I'm not we're all we're all
screwed right uh unfortunately the show
screws we lost a few minutes to what we
think was an AI attack on our sound
decks uh but thank you Pat and uh we'll
give you more time next time if the
robots leads you that's it for me
tonight whatever you're up to keep it
uncensored and stay away from robots
good night
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
use every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you good morning
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it